[Musique]
et maintenant c'est un autre genre de
nouvelle que nous apporte Enrico Matias
je vous apporte la nouvelle tous les
loups tous les agneaux plus jamais ne se
querelle au bord du même ruissau je vous
apporte la nouvelle les lapins et les
mulots sont amis avec les aigles et
s'envolent sur leur dos les savants les
plus habiles réunis dans une tour ont
déclaré maintenant il est temps de
soigner le mal d'amour plus de peur plus
de menace de vaincu ou de vainqueurs les
canons sont à la casse on en fera des
tracteurs les canons sont à la casse on
en fera des
[Musique]
tracteurs je vous apporte la nouvelle
tous les loups tous les agneaux plus
jamais ne se querelle au bord du même
ruiseau je vous apporte la nouvelle les
seigneurs et les banquiers ont ouvert
leur Citadelle à la vraie communauté un
martien sur notre terre m'a dit je veux
vivre ici Satan n'est plus en enfer il
paraît qu'il préfère le paradis les
journaux sont pleins de choses
merveilleuses à raconter les colombes se
repose elle l'avait bien
mérité se repose elle l'avait bien
mérité je vous apporte la nouvelle tous
les loups tous les agneaux plus jamais n
se querelle au bord du même ruissau je
vous apporte la nouvelle les princesses
et puis les rois ce mari et son fidèle
on avait jamais vu ça et je me suis
réveillé en furce tout habillé et tout
le monde a bien ri à la table où je
m'étais endormi voilà ce que j'ai rêvé
bien sûr ça n'existe pas et pourtant moi
je veux croire que ça nous arrivera je
vous apporte la nouvelle tous les loups
tous les agneaux puis jamais de ce que
rêve au bord du même rissau au bord du M
ruisseau M
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ruissau